[Applause]
turn a new page in fear with Hillhouse
comics a terrifying new line of horror
comics generated by Joe Hill the
mastermind behind nos Murata and
lock-and-key get ready to shock your
senses with some of the biggest names in
horror storytelling unleashing their
most disturbing nightmares basket full
of heads June has a supernatural acts
that can decapitate a man in one stroke
but leave his head is still impossibly
alive ranting and mad for revenge how
many heads will she have to collect to
save her boyfriend but dollhouse family
playtime never ends young Alice loves
her antique dollhouse but doesn't know
that it's using her as its plaything
what's welcome to shudder to think
Pennsylvania where skinless men and
antlered women walked the woods and
reality is falling in on itself
Daphne burn a voice called from the
other side
she answered what's a young girl
supposed to do when a charming demon
invades her mind plunge a research ship
screw returns after 40 years lost at sea
they haven't aged a day
but what happened to their eyes and
every issue features a Sea Dogs bonus
story to start a revolution
it'll take blood and guts and werewolves
it'll house comics it's okay if you need
to scream
you